all right Roman
Roman welcome back what's going on man
it's been uh it's probably been a couple
years since you've been here right yeah
a couple years I interviewed you with
your girlfriend Jess yeah is your wife
or girlfriend she's my uh girlfriend I
call her my wife though yeah
and uh
I just found you now are you guys still
together yeah we're together we're
taking a break because um
we're with each other 24 7 and
constantly
and uh
we're going on six years now
uh we're just taking a little break from
each other
um it's for the best we're not separated
or anything we just taking a little
break
and you're still living on the street
yeah we're homeless um waiting for
Housing section eight
what's been going on since last time I
saw you
um well
we ended up moving out to 29 palms and
uh staying with my grandfather well one
of uh my step grandfather's and uh we uh
I was doing my music and had a little
Studio
and uh you can look up my music it's a
royal Talent it's all one word
and uh that's I've been just focusing on
my music like even now you can still on
the street I get on my phone make all my
songs I have at least 200 songs
I have like 300 beats mix and master
produced
uh like five music videos and have two
uh songs on the radio right now
and drugs are still a part of your life
um not as bad as it was but yes but what
are you using this math
I'm like I said yeah no I don't do drugs
but yes still on meth
there was some confusion I remember you
mentioned your mom was uh
an actress yeah my mom was an actress in
the model
and um my dad he's uh
he's out in uh Riverside County
uh he used to stay out here in San
Fernando Valley
and um he got into a bad car accident
and uh it's kind of hard it's like
memory like uh what do you call it when
dementia yeah he's having a little
dementia he remembers who I am but it's
his um
the memories and stuff for all gone and
it's hard for him to think so
um I call them every once in a while
just to check in on them
other than that but I don't really have
any other family and your mom your mom
is disease deceased what was your mom's
name Candace casalicio was there stage
name Candace Mitchell is her real name
so the last video there was lots of
you got lots of criticism in the
comments didn't you I did and honestly I
I understand
completely the way it could look
but
I'm not a narcissist you know and I'm
not
controlling my life I'm not controlling
her or in any way she performed we had
just gotten through a lot and um we both
haven't had slept in a couple days and
right before the interview we were
arguing so it was as if
and it just it just I guess it may look
bad you know but I'm not a bad person
and it's really hurtful that that all
those comments are said like just leave
him and he's no good I had a Roman
before and I'm so glad that I got away
from him and when my wife read that and
our families read that we
it was almost the defamation of
character I think that's the right word
well social media comments or yeah
there's a defination character and it
was [__] because
I'm not like that I love her so much you
know I do everything I can for her man
everything I can she does everything she
can for me I love her with all my heart
and all my soul
and uh yeah
you guys are taking a break for what
reason
um because we got into we got into a
fight an argument because um I thought
she was cheating on me
so um I told her we should just take a
little break
which is she's using as well
yeah
he got a bad heart infection like eight
months ago and um she wasn't she wasn't
supposed to make it when she she fought
it she fought It Off
and now she's doing better but the
doctor did say that um since it the
heart infection travel to her liver her
kidney to her spine and it went to her
brain and I guess
she has slight delusions like like
paranoia and stuff and it's gotten a lot
worse and the drugs don't help at all
it's it's
it's a little much and that's it's also
another reason for
the
separation and and what I mean by
separations we're on that we live on the
same block she has a tent on one one
side of the block and I went on the
other
but
I just um where do you stay now in
Hollywood
you came down the skid row for what
um I came down here I was gonna go to
get my EBT and then
um your friend came along and said hey
um you wanna you wanna do the follow-up
interview I was like
I'm sure why not like I want to clear
some things up anyway
because I don't want my I don't want my
my character to be defined the way that
it was
and um a lot of the commenters or
followers were they were asking to do
separate interviews anyway and I know
everyone wants to hear Jazz inside and
Jess is the type to to she's shy and
she's
he's shy and she's
um
like I said she's going through the
things that she's going through so she
might do it she might not I know that
I'm I'm more than willing to do it
because I need to clear I need to clear
that up
how do you feel about like that like the
comments and stuff well I mean your
struggle is your struggle yeah and
people will everyone's gonna have an
opinion
and you know face tattoos and being on
the street and on drugs that just
puts in an idea in everyone's head of
what your life's all about
and maybe right now that's where you're
at but it doesn't mean that tomorrow you
couldn't turn this around and
straighten out and be
you know a success story too
yeah there's always hope of that I'm
trying I'm trying everything like I said
we're waiting for we're waiting for
housing and
you do have one hell of a lot of face
tattoos yeah thank you
there it's art to me man it's it's my
life and a lot of people like do you
regret it and I'm like no I don't regret
my face tattoos because everything on my
body means something to me every symbol
on me means something to me and and it's
it's
judged as if I'm a bad criminal guy and
like you know I'm once I'm on drugs
that's the only thing I can say that's
bad about me I don't go out and I don't
steal from stores I don't go steal from
people
um I stay out of jail now I don't go to
jail I don't fight with people I'm argue
with people what I do for work for my
little bit of money that I do I
freelance into you know I told you last
time about the computers and stuff
um and actually I unlocked phones and
and do uh tablets laptops and um that
that gets me enough money to eat and
survive during the week
um sometimes I have enough to get a
hotel room and get me and Jesse into a
hotel room
um actually it's most of the time but
the other times we're we're in the tent
and
I want to say that that it's a lot
better than what it was before
like the last time that you interviewed
me and my wife
what have you learned from your years
here
on the streets
not to trust everybody
this is one main thing don't trust
everybody you don't get close to
people
no yeah because once you do it's like
every time they turn on you
and every relationship I've had on the
streets
is it always turned out to be the same
thing
I can't trust them
and um
another thing is that
people are always going to judge me you
know people are always gonna
but I just had to keep pushing I had to
keep going I had to
ignore ignore it and and
you need a success story you're talking
about man
do you feel like you're making your life
more difficult than it needs to be I
mean like whether it's a jury or an
employer
or anyone you meet they're gonna look at
all your face tattoos and have some
preconceived ideas about you yeah I mean
yeah but nowadays too like you can go
into Walmart or Target and people have
face tattoos and they work so
so it's becoming more common than
but my whole face is tied in a hole you
don't you don't regret it oh my God
I
um
even back then I didn't regret it like I
never regretted it like I love my art I
love my face I'm a unique individual
oh my wife loves it and
a lot of people um always stop me like
oh can I take a picture with you and
stuff and I've had offers to work in
magazines and whatnot
um
yeah I don't regret it
oh how old are you 28. what's your
biggest fear now
biggest fear is um
I'm gonna be honestly losing my cat
um I have a I have a I have a cat named
Karma
and Karma was in 29 Palms
um
she was just a kitten and uh they were
shooting the cats because there were so
many of them
and I rescued karma from that happening
to her
and um ever since she's been my life
like when she's my little everything
she's um
she's been there in the rain with me
like every night consistently she comes
and Cuddles up on my chest and she stays
with me she stuck with me she's the
sweetest little cat uh this is just my
everything and uh she got taken stolen
from me
um twice now
that's because people like I said you
can't trust people
and people know that that's my weakness
and that's that's my um
that's my fear is losing my cat and like
something happening to my cat because
that's my biggest responsibility it was
her
is getting clean uh because yeah
see yeah I'm working on that but I don't
smoke as much as I used to I'm down to
like three times a week honestly
I really like I don't smoke as much as I
used to and I sleep every night and I
eat every day
um and eventually yeah I want to get off
that's it because it's not going to give
me nowhere
and it's a waste of money it's a waste
of time
um
and then housing housings I'm excited to
get that soon as I get housing that's
the day I'm gonna stop smoking
completely because I'm not gonna do
anything to jeopardize it's something
that I've been working so hard yeah I
mean a roof over your head will be very
stabilizing
now it's everything I need you know and
I could do my my college and my music
and and
you know the foundation needed to start
I mean successfully
but I did definitely wanted to come in
here and clarify about the The
Narcissist comments and
and the things that were the nasty
things that were said about me without
it just it was really hurtful it hurt it
hurt my feelings and it hurt my family's
feelings
Jessica's families and Jessica
was
do is like flabbergasted at the comments
that were being made she's like you're
not even like that like why are people
being like that why are people saying
that why are people being so nasty
and I was nasty what people said
very very nasty and
and um wrong
so
all right Roman great seeing you again
yeah thank you man I wish you lots of
luck with housing and uh
with Jess and all that
um like I said about just too um I'll
talk with her and see if she'll be
interested yeah let her know
um
I think it's important though so she can
get her side out too because I want
everyone to see that and again for that
all right everyone thank you very much